there is no protection from this horror
it's a scene that's become hauntingly
familiar in ukraine
the retrieval of bodies from makeshift
graves
relentless work and this is only the
start
officials say the mass burial site holds
the remains of hundreds of civilians
how are you feeling
not very good
this woodland on the edge of the city of
israel a testament to the reality of
russia's war
you told us about this mass burial site
yesterday and we're here today
looking around like how do you feel
um
the site is next to an actual cemetery
but there's no such dignity here
there's the unmistakable smell of death
in the air as the police and the other
forensic experts begin the process of
digging up the bodies trying to identify
them and trying to work out how they
were killed you'll see
on these makeshift markers some of them
have names have the dates of when they
were killed over there
or they have numbers the numbers meaning
that the identity is is not definitely
known and in that case dna samples will
be taken as the police try to work out
who has been buried here
some of the victims are thought to have
died in russian artillery and missile
strikes
but one official says there's also
evidence of torture
claiming a rope was found around the
neck of the first body to be exhumed and
injuries to the limbs
it's not just civilians buried here
there was also a mass grave holding at
least 17 ukrainian soldiers
their bodies now being recovered
a local man was damning of a group of
ukrainians whose job
russian troops used the woodland as a
base as well as for burials
isiam had been a key prize in their
invasion until ukraine snatched it back
now the focus here is on finding justice
for the victims
like this family all killed on the same
day
or this woman
who lived through world war ii
only to die in war in 2022
debra haynes sky news izum